باين لديه عقيدة موآب لديه خطة لهذا اليوم
بعد ولكن في اليوم التالي لنبدو سلسين
من هذه الأشياء التي تظهر على الشاشة ما يريد بايدن الترويج له
هنا في المنطقة، أولا وقبل كل شيء، هناك مبادرة لتشجيع إنشاء
دولة فلسطينية المملكة العربية السعودية البريطانية التي تضم
التطبيع مع إسرائيل هو بالطبع دولة فلسطينية
من دون حماس ورد عسكري على إيران وأذرعها
هذه هي عقيدة بايدن ولكن لديه المزيد
الأشياء التي أرادها
الترويج لإحياء السلطة الفلسطينية من خلال التفاهم
فليكن هنا حل الدولتين موب حماس لا
سيكون في هذه الصورة ولكن لا يوجد شيء للقيام به
لن تكون إسرائيل، ولن تحكم غزة، بل دولة
الفلسطيني هنا هناك عمليات أحادية تتشكل
مثل على سبيل المثال الرغبة في الاعتراف بالدولة الفلسطينية
هذا محظور وهذا ما ظهر في تلك المقالة التي كتبها توماس
ويتبنى فريدمان في نيويورك نفس المبدأ
وقال بايدن أيضا وزير الخارجية البريطاني نفس الشيء بالضبط
هذه الأشياء التي نعتبرها هي ديفيد كاميرون
نحن نفكر في الاعتراف بالدولة الفلسطينية مرة أخرى
قبل الاتفاق مع إسرائيل لست تحت الولاية
أنا بريطاني ولست النجمة رقم 51 على العلم
العهد أعيش في دولة إسرائيل
أن الشعب اليهودي حصل على كل ما يقوله بايدن اليوم
وكل ما يقوله كاميرون اليوم يشكل تهديدا كبيرا
إن وجود دولة يهودية في أرض إسرائيل هو نحن
سنواصل التأكد من أن دولة إسرائيل تفعل شيئًا ما
ما هو جيد لدولة إسرائيل ليس ما هو جيد لانتخاباتها
بايدن، في رأيي، هو كل شيء شمال النهر
الإنجيل هو ما قرأوه وهو مكثف للغاية
يشرف مجلس شاطئ عسقلان الإقليمي على المنطقة بأكملها
وستكون هذه مستوطنة نير ديبوري اليهودية لك
ويأتي لنا عنوان حول المعضلة الشخصية الصعبة
من رؤساء الأجهزة الأمنية الذين كانوا هناك يوم السابع
وفي تشرين الأول/أكتوبر، سوف ترى النخبة الأمنية بأكملها هذا الأمر
لقد تم بالفعل الاستيلاء على رؤساء الجيش ورؤساء شيفاك
المسؤولية وقالوا أنهم سيذهبون أو ينوون الذهاب
المنزل السؤال هو بالطبع مسألة توقيت كل شيء
لا يزال هناك قتال في الجنوب وربما أيضاً قتال في الشمال
ومن المؤكد أنهم لا ينوون البقاء بعد الآن أيضًا
واستجوب الجيش فلا يتجاوز هذه الزاوية
نقطة مهمة جدًا للأيام القليلة القادمة من راماتال
روش حبق، روش هامان، دوف الجنوب، وأكثر من ذلك بكثير
كبار المسؤولين في التحالف يقولون لك
في تقديرنا، يواجه نتنياهو صفقة لا لبس فيها
أنظروا أيضاً، نحن نتحدث عن نتنياهو في الثانية
السياسي والسياسي عادة ما يكون لهما ساقان
أخيراً يتخذ نتنياهو قراراته السياسية
أكثر من السياسة التي ننظر إليها هنا
مسألة المساعدات الإنسانية فيها تناقض
يتمتع الليكود بالقوة اليهودية والصهيونية الدينية
في النهاية يذهب مع المساعدات الإنسانية الموجودة
ولذلك فإن الضغط الأمريكي موضع تقدير في التحالف
نتنياهو، من أجل إرضاء الأميركيين، سيعقد صفقة
خطف وربما من أجل كسر وقف إطلاق النار أولا
يخبرنا مسؤول سياسي أن الأمر سيستغرق بضعة أسابيع أخرى
الرحلة وهذا إعطاء ما قاله ليئور التفاصيل
التفاصيل الصغيرة ليست صغيرة جدًا، هذا ما نتحدث عنه
تتحدث الأرقام عن الطرادات التي سيتم إطلاقها
الشيء الذي سيستغرق عدة أسابيع لن يحدث، لا
الأسبوع القادم، وليس خلال أسبوعين، وسوف أقوم بتعيينك
الدولة وليس حماس وأنا أعرف الكثير من الآباء
هذا يشعر تمامًا بنفس الشيء الذي لا نتوقعه و
من حماس أن نحب أطفالنا لا أن نحميهم
الاطفال
لنا نرسل أطفالنا
للجيش ودرسوا في مدرسة أن هناك دولة لا تفعل ذلك
ستكون هناك محرقة أخرى وماتوا في محرقة أخرى لأنه لا يوجد محرقة
لا يوجد بلد
الأمن ولا أحد
تعالوا لتهتموا بأي عضو كنيست، لا أعرف كيف
يستيقظون في الصباح ولا أعرف كيف هم
يخرج
من الداخل، لا رئيس الأركان، ولا وزير الدفاع، ولا رئيس الأركان
الحكومة ليست فنانة، ولا أعرف كيف هم
يستدير
هذا كل شيء
لو أنهم جميعاً دمروه
حياة الطفل هذه هي الخراب للجميع
الحياة إذن ليست كافية، عليك أن تحكم
إلقاء اللوم على الجميع في مثل هذا الإغفال، فهو ليس إغفالاً خسرناه
ملايين
دولار